[Music]
what is up everybody I just saw Avengers
infinity war and it was amazing really
it truly was everything that I hoped it
would be in this video I'll be talking
about the post-credit scenes and what it
means they're obviously going to be some
spoilers in this video so if you haven't
seen the movie go see it and also not
really sure what you clicked on this
video if you haven't seen it but there
will be spoilers for the end of the
movie and for the post-credits scene as
well last chance to turn away because
here we go the movie ends with Thanos
snappiness fingers and eliminating half
of the universe we know that this is at
random because during the movie he says
he proposed that his planet eliminate
half of the population randomly so I
think it's safe to assume that when he
snaps his fingers to wipe out half the
universe it's done randomly after he
snaps his fingers people begin to
randomly disappear including half of the
Avengers so let's go to the post-credits
scene where we see Nick Fury and agent
Hill and an SUV together the scene
starts with fury talking to agent hill
asking if there's been any word from
Stark she replies no but then the device
that she's holding picks up multiple
bogies in Wakanda fury asks her if it's
the same energy signals as New York and
she replies ten times bigger right after
she says this an SUV comes swerving and
crashing into the car that they're in so
this part of the scene is pretty
self-explanatory there's been no
communication with Stark because he's
stranded on Titan currently and he's way
too far from earth for communications to
be made and then of course the energy
signals that agent Hill is detecting as
Stannis's army after the SUV runs into
them they get out and check on the SUV
finding that no one is in the car
immediately after a helicopter crashes
into a building this is obviously the
result of people vanishing from
existence due to Thanos snapping his
fingers and eliminating half of the
universe fury then says call control
Code Red then he turns around and agent
hill is vanishing once she vanishes he
runs back to his SUV to the backseat
grabs a device and then runs to the back
of the car
once he's to the back of the car he hits
a button on the device and then he
himself begins to vanish
as he vanishes the device drops of the
floor and the camera zooms in on it it
says sending dot dot and then the
Captain Marvel symbol pops up on it
that's right Captain Marvel that means
that she exists in the current time or
she's at least known about and
accessible in the current time because
otherwise Nick Fury wouldn't call her
of course we've known about the Captain
Marvel solo movie for some time now with
brie Larson's confirmed to be playing
Captain Marvel herself Carol Danvers aka
Captain Marvel is one of the most
powerful superheroes in the Marvel
Universe so it's very fitting that they
would call her and after stano's has
successfully wiped out half of the
universe
Captain Marvel has superhuman strength
can fly and can even shoot energy bursts
from her hands she may be just what the
remaining Avengers need to defeat Thanos
well that is it for my Avengers infinity
war post-credit seeing explanation video
let me know what you guys thought was
the best part about Avengers infinity
war and if you're really excited for
Captain Marvel to make an appearance
also don't forget to enter a giveaway
for a chance to win a full surround
sound speaker system all you need to do
to enter is subscribe to my channel
subscribe to the stupendous wave leave a
like and drop a comment with your
favorite superhero from Marvel DC or
otherwise thank you so much for watching
woof woof
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people
to see if we could become something more
so when they needed us